president biden celebrates passage of
the largest pork bill in american
history
the white house continues to deny a
crisis on the border while incentivizing
a crisis on the border and the new york
times finally finds an employee they'll
defend
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the bench shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
slash been a lot to get to today we're
gonna get to it in just one second first
you know the government is now blowing
out the dollar this is what they're
doing they're spending more money than
has ever been created by god or man
at some point the bill will come due you
might want to be diversified into
something that is not actually the
united states dollar you might want to
be diversified into something that has
never been worth zero i'm talking of
course about gold if you're talking
about something that hedges against
inflation and uncertainty in the market
gold is your thing this is why i should
talk to my friends over at birch gold
birch gold just passed a major milestone
10 000 customers that's 10 000 people
who have a plan
against radical leftist policies driving
up our national debt and devaluing the
dollar
if you've been waiting to call birch
gold to convert an ira or eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
now would be the time through april 30th
on qualifying purchases when you
purchase precious metals with birch gold
they'll send you
a free home safe which is a pretty solid
deal we've given away books we've given
away silver this is their biggest
giveaway ever text ben to 47 47 47
for your free information kit on
precious metals ira or to speak with a
birch gold representative today
with ten thousand customers they have an
a plus rating with the better business
bureau countless five five-star reviews
they can help you too
text ben to 47 47 47 for your free safe
with purchase again talk to my friends
over at birch gold there's never been a
better time in human history
to hedge against inflation than right
now go check them out right now text ben
47 47 today and work with my friends
over at birch gold okay so
here's the good news the good news is it
is pretty clear at this point pretty
obvious at this point
that as soon as you get the vaccine as
soon as that vaccine kicks in you know
two weeks
three weeks a month in you should be
able to go back to your regular life
this is becoming more and more obvious
every single day now members of our
government are trying to prolong the
agony because again
this agony is being used by president
house plans and crew
in order to push forward the broadest
spending bills in american history and
they want to do more but
the reality is that we are now in the
waning days of the pandemic according to
pfizer
they say the real world data from israel
suggests that vaccine is now 94
effective 94 effective in preventing
asymptomatic infections meaning that the
vaccine could significantly reduce
transmission
according to reuters also pfizer says
that the real world data out of israel
shows
its vaccine effectiveness is 97 in
preventing symptomatic disease
all symptomatic disease as well as
severe critical disease and death
their release notes that 80 of the
tested specimens in israel were the
apparently very very scary b117uk
variant so you've heard all about these
variants the mexican variant and the
and the uk variants and the south
african variant the evidence thus far
shows that the vaccine is extremely
effective against the virus and let's be
real about this even if we're not
we eventually are going to have to go
back to our daily lives we're eventually
going to have to go back to work this
cannot last internally and
by the way we are now drawing near the
end and we're at the lowest infection
rate since the beginning of the pandemic
we are not seeing optics spring break is
happening in florida we're not seeing
upticks in florida
if there are upticks it's among people
who are young and relatively
invulnerable to covet 19.
the vaccines are going out at an
extraordinary rate a couple million a
day at this point
we have now apparently purchased
according to the washington post
four times the number of vaccines as the
number of adults
in the united states because i don't
know we're going to use all those extra
vaccines for it theoretically we could
just give them to allies or we could
tranch them out as booster shots or
whatever but here's the rea we're at the
end of this thing okay
we're now very close to the end of this
thing and the data are clear
once you get the vaccine you should be
able to take off the max the mask and
you should be able to hang out with
whoever you want whether or not they are
vaccinated
and if somebody chooses not to get
vaccinated that is their own problem if
they then get infected that is their
problem
but people who are vaccinated should
feel pretty invulnerable to covet
because statistically speaking
they are pretty invulnerable to covid
you know who acknowledges this
the cdc who have been lying to you so
the cdc will say that if you've been
vaccinated you shouldn't fly
vaccinated you shouldn't get together
with large groups of other vaccinated
people
the cdc will say to you that you should
not get together with people who are
unvaccinated
in larger than one family groups all
that is crap you know how i know that's
crap because the cdc says that if you're
vaccinated and you're in a room with a
person who then tests
covet positive you don't even have to
quarantine which means they're not
worried about you transmitting it to
others or getting infected
which means that this thing is over for
the people who are vaccinated and we all
know it
and now everybody's just lying about it
in the media at the cdc
they're all lying about this because
they would prefer that the coveted
crisis be prolonged
so they can quote build back better okay
this is now being used as an excuse
as it has been for the last couple of
months by the democrats in order to push
forward
world-beating change gavin newsom
admitted this in california
he said the recovery is not just going
to be a recovery it's going to be world
we're going to change
everything about the way california
works meaning we're going to blow out
the spending meaning we're going to blow
out the taxation because
now is the opportunity for us to push
our quote unquote equitable solutions
now you may have noticed this pattern
before from the political left the
political left has been using climate
change as their big bugaboo in order to
scare people
into vast redistributionist policies
that crack crackdown on free markets and
free individual rights
and the idea is that that climate change
is such a vast threat to the american
population and
the global population and we need to
sacrifice all of our rights all of our
economic freedoms our prosperity
in order to stop this vast threat the
thing is most people across the world
don't actually agree with that most
people are not into that
particularly in the developing world
where they would just like to you know
not burn dung for fuel
right that's they would like to live
past the age of 50.
in those places it seems like
carbon-based fuels pretty good idea one
of the great inventions of mankind
carbon-based fuels
but now that climate change has proven
itself not to be
enough of an impetus for the sort of
socialistic change that our new ruling
class would like
they've decided that kovid is the
impetus for that and so they're going to
prolong this as long as they humanly can
there is no reason for joe biden to be
walking around with the mask he's
vaccinated
if joe biden really wanted to get past
the pandemic at this point he would be
taking off the mask and telling
everybody else that you can do that once
you've been vaccinated for a month
but president house plant right this
barely sentient human who's gonna be
giving a speech tonight i don't even
know how he's gonna give the speech
tonight and you watch him on camera
and i honest to god i do not know how
they think that this man is going to
give a speech
he he might be able to sustain it for
like 10 minutes but any longer than that
and it's gonna be a problem for him
it's gonna be quick cuts like an mtv
music video from 1987
it's just gonna be like one shot of him
saying a word and then another shot of
him saying word
and then they'll string it all together
and they'll put a little bit of soft
guitar music
underneath to make you feel like they
did it all in one shot
but president house plant is a is a
friendly face for the sort of radical
change that we are watching democrats
implement
on the back of lies about the
continuation of a crisis this is not a
crisis anymore
we are not in crisis i'm living in
florida in california they're still
treating this
as a crisis even though the crisis is
waning in florida
it is not a crisis it hasn't been in
crisis for a long time when i say crisis
i mean icu's being overwhelmed
i mean vast numbers of people outside of
old age homes which are protected in
places like florida dying i mean all of
the businesses
being shut this has not been a crisis
first for many weeks
at this point and florida's been open
since the summer the rest of america is
opening up
the crisis is waning the crisis is like
this close to being over
okay that is what the science says and i
follow the science and
the data not to science which is
politically driven nonsense
being pushed by the way by supposed
scientific minds like rochelle lentz get
to cdc who's just doing the bidding of
the biden administration
and dr anthony fauci over at the niaid
who is over there doing the biden
administration's bidding they're not
following the science
they're following the politics because
you watch joe biden
president houseplant is supposed to sign
into law this giant
quote-unquote coveted relief package
that has nothing to do with govid he's
going to sign that on friday
by monday they will be talking about how
hope is on the horizon
and how we can all get back to our
regular lives remember some of us
predict this as early as january
what i said you go back you can find the
tape what i said is that
we were already going to be on the wane
by late january by the time he took
office
and then he was going to jump in front
of the parade declare universal masking
people were going to give him credit the
vaccines were already going to be going
out
people are going to then give biden
credit and then he was going to declare
the coveted pandemic over
once he ran through some change so that
prediction looks pretty good today
but the fundamental point is still this
we don't actually need
this giant blockbuster spending bill we
don't need all of this
giant enormous keynesian spending in
order to recover
given the fact that this entire economic
depression was caused artificially by
government shutdowns
it was caused artificially by an
extraneous shock
namely the virus and once the virus is
on the wane everybody's going to go back
to business
and guess what before the virus we had
the most booming economy that we'd had
in this country for half a century
and yet that's what needs fundamental
change they're not trying to change what
the situation was during covet they're
trying to change the situation
before covid when we had the best
economy that we've had in 50 years
with serious wage growth particularly at
the bottom of the economic spectrum
with high employment rates for minority
communities they're trying to change
that
that's what they're trying to change and
they're using covet as an excuse
and that is why they refuse to
acknowledge the obvious which is that
covet is basically over at this point it
is
not only on the way and we are like this
far from it being over i'm gonna keep
saying that over and over until people
get it through their heads because i
understand we all have a psychological
block now
i understand that we have the
psychological block about oh no can i
even see other people am i going to get
back to normal the answer is yes get out
there
get back to normal after you've had the
vaccine end of story we'll get some more
of this in just one second first
whether you're an avid news watcher or
in serious need of a distraction
unplugging yourself is easier said than
done well when i want to rest
these peepers and instead i just want to
listen to some nice classical music and
calm down in the afternoons
i need my wireless earbuds and i will
tell you the best pair of wireless
earbuds they are my raycons whether
you're catching up on your favorite news
podcast or binging in audiobook
or powering through your workout with a
pumped up playlist a pair of raycons in
your ears can make
all the difference in the world no
dangling wires or stems to get in the
way raycons come in a range of stylish
colors
always the comfortable in-ear fit for a
more discreet look raycons are built to
perform anywhere anytime with water and
sweat resistant construction and
bluetooth that pairs quickly and
seamlessly you've got enough battery
life for six hours of playtime which
means you can unplug
for quite a while the best part raycon
makes great sound accessible to everyone
with wireless earbuds starting at half
the price
of other premium wireless audio brands
raycon is offering 15 off all their
products today for my listeners here's
what you have to do to get it go to
buyrecon.com that's all
get 15 off your entire raycon order feel
free to grab a pair and a spare that's
off at byraycon.com once more
by raycon.com ben okay so it's not just
me saying this
about the waning of the pandemic dr
martin makari who's been a guest on this
program many times from johns hopkins
university he has a piece today in the
wall street journal
and he says that basically after you've
had this thing for a month the vaccine
you're done he says the center for
disease control and prevention has lost
a lot of credibility during the covet 19
pandemic by being late or wrong on
testing masks vaccine allocation and
school reopening
staying consistent with that pattern
this week three months after the vaccine
rollout began
the cdc finally started telling
vaccinated people they can have normal
interactions with other vaccinated
people but only in highly limited
circumstances
given the impressive effectiveness of
the vaccine that should have been
immediately obvious by applying
scientific inference and common sense
part of the new guidelines are
absolutely restrictive for example the
cdc did not withdraw its advice to avoid
air travel after vaccination
a year of pre-vaccine experience has
demonstrated that airplanes are not a
source of spread
the guidelines do approve a vaccinated
people meeting with low risk on
vaccinated ones but only with people
from the same household and in a small
private setting so much for restaurants
birthday parties and weddings
an unpublished study conducted by the
israeli health ministry and pfizer shows
vaccination reduced transmission by 89
to 94
and almost totally prevented
hospitalization and death according to
press reports
immunity kicks in fully about four weeks
after the first vaccine dose and then
you're essentially bulletproof with the
added safety of wearing a mask indoors
for a few more weeks or months a
practical necessity in public places
even if not a medical one since you
can't tell on site if somebody is immune
there's little a vaccinated person
should be discouraged from doing on a
positive note the cdc did say that fully
vaccinated people who are asymptomatic
don't need to be tested but that obvious
recommendation should have come two
months ago before wasting so many tests
on people who have high levels of
circulating antibodies from vaccination
in its guidance the cdc says the risks
of infection and vaccinated people
cannot be completely eliminated true we
don't have conclusive data that
guarantees vaccination reduces risks to
zero because we never will
we're operating in the realm of medical
discretion based on the best available
data as practicing physicians have
always done
the cdc highlights the vaccine's
stunning success but is
ridiculously cautious about its
implications the cdc acknowledges
potential risks of isolation but doesn't
go into details it's time to liberate
vaccinated people to restore their
relationships and rebuild their lives
that would encourage
vaccination by giving hesitant people a
vivid incentive to have the shots
as people yearn to be with their loved
ones and rebuild communities we
shouldn't repeat the mistakes of the
past
we can't exaggerate the public health
threat as we did with hospital
visitation rules and keep crushing the
human spirit with
overly restrictive policies for
vaccinated americans
he says what am i allowed to do after
i've been vaccinated once a month has
passed after your first shot go back to
normal
dr marti makari writing that he happens
to be correct but
again the goal here for the democrats is
to never
let go of this we saw nancy pelosi
yesterday literally saying that she
wants another tranche of spending
she wants another transfer spending
because you never know what the virus is
going to do
but let's be real about this the
democrats have been using this virus as
an excuse to pass a completely
unnecessary bill it is completely
unnecessary
the vast majority of the funding is
going to people who did not lose their
jobs the vast majority of the funding is
going
by the way not even to individual
american citizens it's going to bailouts
for union pension funds
it's going to bailouts for states and
localities that blew out their own
budgets
and who by the way have not lost tax
revenue during this downturn because
the first relief bills actually
increased tax revenues in certain states
but nancy pelosi is super happy about
this here's nancy pelosi yesterday
saying this is the most consequential
legislation of our lifetime she's not
wrong about this by the way
okay this is very consequential
legislation it sets up brand new
entitlement programs that quote unquote
only last a year but are designed to
last far longer
it creates essentially incentives the
old welfare incentives to have kids out
of wedlock because
again you get paid by the government to
have kids
not only do you get paid by the
government to have kids there are no
restrictions with regard to
having a job or not having a job there
are no work requirements
there's nothing that encourages marriage
anywhere in there
not only that again this is a giant
bailout for states that have blown out
their own pocketbooks
it is a it is a bonanza used car
sales lemon that's all this thing is
here's nancy pelosi calling it the most
consequential legislation of our
lifetime
i think i can safely say and i've said
this to my colleagues in the house on
the democratic side
this is the most consequential
legislation that many of us will
ever be a party to who knows what the
future may bring
but nonetheless on this day we celebrate
because we are honoring a promise made
by our president
as we join with him in promising that
help
is on the way by the way help should
have been on the way in
i don't know august okay the reality is
that there were covert relief packages
passed
all the way up in bipartisan fashion
during the trump administration this
thing was passed along pure party lines
why
because the pandemic is basically over
okay the pandemic is
is done okay now we are spending 1.9
trillion dollars more money than has
ever been seen by god or man
spending money that has not yet been
created we are spending all of that
money
to do what to do what we are now
actively encouraging people not to go
back to work we're providing enhanced
unemployment incentives that go all the
way until
september september are you insane
september again we have the lowest rates
of infection since the beginning of the
pandemic
i would say at this point most states
are wide open for business the
unemployment rate in places that have
remained wide open like south dakota is
like three percent
by the way the national unemployment
rate is 6.3 percent which is not
wonderful but it's certainly not crisis
levels we're not talking about the 20
that we were at even a few months ago
now is the time we need to spend 1.9
trillion dollars on a bunch of nonsense
now naturally this is popular if you
send people checks that's popular
but over time what's going to be shown
is that it doesn't actually raise people
out of poverty to just send them checks
that has never been a solution the war
on poverty tried this with 22 trillion
dollars worth of checks
over the past several decades it has not
lowered the poverty rate in the united
states
you can't just sign people checks and
then hope that's gonna cure poverty
that is not how poverty gets cured there
are steps to escape poverty
but those steps generally speaking are
reliant on individual decision making
like don't have kids out of wedlock
finish high school and get a job by the
way if you follow those steps you will
not spend your life in poverty
statistically speaking according to the
left wing brookings institute
so what exactly does this bill do well
it blows out the national debt obviously
i know we don't care about this i know
in bipartisan fashion we no longer care
about the national debt and i'm not
going to pretend that i'm sanguine about
republicans who completely waived
all of their duty when it came to
blowing out the national debt when trump
was president they blew out the national
debt they spent four trillion dollars a
year republicans did because trump did
not care about cutting spending and now
biden's answer to that is what if we go
to six trillion dollars a year that's
what he wants
he doesn't just want another 2 trillion
spent here that's by the way
on the side of the 4 trillion budget not
inclusive of the 4 trillion
budget so we're already at 6 trillion he
wants to spend another 2 trillion
dollars on infrastructure so he wants to
double double the budget
in the middle of a non-pandemic because
we are not in the middle of a pandemic
anymore guys
we're not so we are going to double the
national debt essentially
uh or at least the household national
debt over the past year
over the past year the pandemic coupled
with its effects on the economy led to
an unprecedented amount of federal
spending according to heritage
foundation
in fiscal year 2020 it was over 50 000
per household this year we can expect
another 45 000
per household the total national debt
has risen to 27.9 trillion dollars that
is more than 215
000 dollars per household and by the way
a lot of households don't pay tax which
means that if you're one of the 50
percent of households that do pay tax
your actual share of the national debt
is more like four hundred and
four hundred and thirty thousand dollars
and if you do it
by actually tranching out the the tax
rates if you're at the top end of the
spectrum you owe millions of dollars to
the federal government
congress is just blowing out the
spending it doesn't actually care about
coveted relief obviously because
again the amount that's actually spent
on quote-unquote covenant 19 relief
for public health is like 10 of the
package
hey it is a it is a massive spend on
teachers unions who have not reopened
their schools
it spends money all the way up until
2026 it spends more money on schools in
2026 than 2021 it's the same about the
pandemic
it also blows out welfare expansion
right it completely reverses decades of
attempts to curb
the welfare state according to the
heritage foundation the legislation
includes benefit increases and
expansions for a variety of safety net
programs including unemployment
insurance affordable care act subsidies
the earned income tax credit which will
now be going to people who did not
actually pay taxes
cash welfare payments and much much more
it also
destroys incentives to find work marry
or increase earnings
now again i understand the argument that
you want women staying home with kids as
opposed to working
because it's better for kids not to be
in daycare right that's an argument
that's now being made by people on the
left women should have the option to
stay home more with their kids if
they're single moms and such
but we should have incentives that
actually encourage people to get married
okay marriage is a solution to poverty
staying home on a government check
is not a solution to poverty as it turns
out it gives giant handouts to special
interests
90 billion dollars from the general
public to pad out pension plans
that is directly directly oriented
toward big labor
57 billion dollars going toward
transportation in a way that privileges
unionized workers
overall 500 billion dollars that is
generally
generally directed toward paying off
democratic political allies and by the
way these stimulus checks
they're not going to actually cure
whatever economic problems ill the
united
states again most americans still have
jobs
the vast majority of americans are still
employed and that's going to get better
not worse
as we reopen the economy and yet we're
giving all these people who are already
employed
1400 bucks a pop i understand why you
like it i would like it too if i were
receiving 1400
in free money but no money is free money
and money doesn't just grow on trees
contrary to popular
modern monetary theory opinion
by the way people have extraordinary
savings rates right now we are paying
off our credit card debt that's what
we're using the money for
right now hey these are not stimulative
because again the way that you stimulate
the economy is by creating new products
and services
and you stimulate demand by reopening
your economy so this is a giant
boondoggle this bill
an enormous boondoggle but what is this
really about it's really about the
politics of the situation so joe biden
says everything in the bill addresses a
real need which of course is a lie
it is a lie the vast majority of this
bill does not address a real need
for the one millionth time the economic
shortfall this year is supposed to be
450 billion dollars thanks to covid this
bill
is more than four times the amount in
spending here's joe biden being
incoherent
everything in the american rescue plan
addresses a real need
including investments to fund our entire
vaccination effort
more vaccines more vaccinators
and more vaccination sites millions more
americans will get tested
including home testing schools will soon
have the funding and resources that
reopen
safely on national imperative the
american rescue plan
the partnership between johnson and
johnson and merck
proves we can do big things important
things in this country
okay all of this stuff was already
underway schools have been open in this
country in a wide variety of states four
months at this point mike has been in
school
all year long in florida florida never
closed its schools
as far as the the notion that testing
and tracing was ever going to be
effective testing and tracing was never
effective throughout the pandemic in the
united states it just was not
okay i know that was it was portrayed as
the cural it was not okay and as far as
the vaccine
is being tranched out that started under
trump it continued to under biden
end of story so do you need 1.9 trillion
dollars in spending of course not
okay but what this is really about is
about what comes next it's not just
about this it's about what comes next
it's about now we're in a new era of
hope hope has broken out on the horizon
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let us talk about your sleep quality so
when i climb into bed at night after my
kids have fully exhausted me
i need to be sleeping on the best sheets
available and those are bull and branch
sheets without a doubt they're so good i
threw out all my other sheets i only
have bull and brand sheets the signature
hem sheets from bowling branch are best
seller for
a reason buttery soft lightweight
organic cotton and a classic sateen
weave for sheets that get softer over
time they're not too hot not too cool
the perfect year-round sheets for most
sleepers bowling branch focuses on
quality over quantity no inflated thread
counts because more isn't always better
you know when somebody says it's a
thousand thread count that really
doesn't make any difference the question
is what is the sheet actually made out
of
bulletin branch signature sheets come in
seven beautiful colors in all sizes from
twin on
up to california king made to a higher
standard 100 organic cotton ethical
production thoughtful attention to every
detail there's nothing worse than fitted
sheets that don't fit
bowling branch offers 17 inch deep
fitted sheets and labeled sides to help
you make your bed beautifully every
single time
because you know those little things do
make a big difference jordan peterson
has told you that you ought to make her
bed
bowling branch makes it super easy
experience the best sheets you've ever
felt at bull and branch dot com
get 15 off your first set of sheets when
you use promo code shapiro at checkout
that's bull and branch b-o-l-l
and branch dot com promo code shapiro
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch.com promo code shapiro and get 15
off your first set of sheets okay so
this massive democrat-only bill is very
popular
but not only that it is the turning
point in how we speak about covet
some of us have been saying cove is on
the way that's why this bill is
unnecessary mitch mcconnell says this
right senator minority leader
thanks to the complete fussery by the
way you thought those georgia senate
seats didn't matter
yeah they mattered a little bit because
now we have established these giant new
entitlement programs that are going to
be extraordinarily hard to roll back as
we blow out the debt for all time
here is mitch mcconnell saying if the
economy booms this is going to have
nothing to do with it which happens to
be correct because the economy was
booming before covet
the economy will boom after covet let's
just all go back to our regular lives
and i don't know
not spend money that has never been
created not
borrow trillions of dollars from foreign
creditors here's mitch mcconnell saying
this he's ripped up and down for this of
course
we're doing damage to the future of this
country
by spending dramatically more money
than we obviously need at this
particular
point at which time the economy is
coming back
people are getting vaccine we're on the
way out of this
we're about to have a boom and if we do
have a boom
it will have absolutely nothing to do
with this 1.9 trillion dollars
that is exactly right but again the
media will never let this happen right
whatever boom happens from now on
they're going to credit biden with now
again i predicted this last year i said
there was a high likelihood that after
covert was over there was going to be
this big economic boom
that that biden was going to take
advantage of the economic boom
to put in place a bunch of crappy
radical policy that completely
undermined the american economy so what
you're going to see
is the next couple years are going to be
a spending spree everybody's going to go
nuts they're going to go wild there'll
be price inflation over the course of
time it's already starting to happen
again because demand is starting to
return because people are going back to
their regular lives
and then the effects of this economic
policy is going to be felt then you're
going to feel it but it's not immediate
and it could take a few years for all of
this to kick in because it usually takes
the economy a few years for these sorts
of massive spending efforts to kick in
you see this in the 1960s you can see
the growth rates
throughout the beginning of the lbj term
and then by the end of the lbj term
they're starting to weigh in by the
1970s the growth rates have basically
petered out
right so it takes a little while to feel
when you have completely botched the
entire american economy but that's
exactly what we're doing right now it's
just going to take a little while for us
to get there
and now joe biden has declared of course
as you would expect that now that he got
his legislative priority his big win now
there's hope so there wasn't hope a week
ago when it was perfectly obvious that
code was ending
no no now there's hope because obviously
obviously things are different now
because he got what he wanted
because for months at this point it has
been perfectly obvious this thing was
coming to an end
and it was just a question of can they
sneak in under the wire
and spend more money than has ever been
created
there is light at the end of this dark
tunnel in the past year
but we cannot let our guard down now or
assume the victory is inevitable
together we're going to get through this
pandemic and usher in a healthier
and more hopeful future so there is real
reason for hope folks
there's real reason for hope i promise
you oh well amazing that is a different
message
than we've heard from joe biden right
for for the last several months it's
been
a doom and gloom are coming doom and
gloom and
you know doom and gloom we're all going
to attend
it's been all darkness and dim and then
they pass a bill that he wants and
suddenly
hope is uh happy days are here again
like can everybody see how transparent
this is it's unbelievably
transparent clearly transparent
and democrats of course are excited
about this they're ignoring the fact
that there are economic risks to all
this which we'll get to in a moment here
is chuck schumer saying
help is on the way now whenever chuck
schumer says help is on the way reach
for your wallet because
right now they're inflating your wallet
don't worry guys they they take with one
hand
from you and they give with the other
but what they take is usually more than
what they give
okay it's all fun and games until the
two by four behind their back comes out
here's chuck schumer
so what do we say to america we say to
america help is on the way
help is on the way you will receive
fourteen hundred dollar checks by the
end of march
help is on the way vaccines will be
available far more quickly to far more
people
at a in a shorter time help is on the
way
our schools will open safely and more
quickly
than we thought help is on the way okay
now here's the thing again the democrats
require the presence of president house
plant here
to ram this thing through because people
find him completely unthreatening it's
the reason why they won't trot him out
because the more they trot him out the
more it's clear that this man is losing
it and the fact that he is losing it
means that he is not really in control
of his own administration
yesterday for example joe biden just
ignored questions on doing press
conferences he has now gone longer than
any president in 100 years according to
abc news
not doing oppressor why because he can't
answer questions because he's not a
sentient person
okay he is a house plant he is barely
alive and he is there to beautify your
dining room that is what he is there to
do for the democrats he is there to make
your house
look slightly more colorful that's
pretty much uh to to
he's hiding the water stain on the
carpet that's what joe biden is
he's a house plant who hides the giant
democratic water stain
on the carpet barely alive not providing
a lot but taking a little sunlight
letting out a little bit of of oxygen
and that's pretty much what he's there
to do
the surplus will if we have a surplus
we're going to share it with the rest of
the world
okay i mean there is an injury in them
and meanwhile
what's going to happen here well
inflation is going to be the long-term
cost here
according to the new york times while
the biden administration's ambitious
effort to sell the pandemics deep
economic wounds made its way through
congress i love the way they put that
it's
that's all this is it's an attempt to
sell the nation's deep economic wounds
by you know spending a trillion dollars
more
than actual direct relief to the
american people proponents insisted that
funding 1.9 trillion dollars to american
households and businesses wouldn't
wouldn't unshackle a long vanquished
monster inflation
officials at the federal reserve have
said there's little cause for worry but
as the legislation moved toward the
finish line
inflation prospects increasingly
influenced political commentary and
wall street trading the worries reflect
expectations of a racket
rapid economic expansion as businesses
reopen and the pandemic recedes
millions are still unemployed layoffs
remain high but for workers with secure
jobs higher spending seems almost
certain in the months ahead as
vaccinations prompt americans to get out
and about
deploying savings built up over the last
year okay what this does is it devalues
your savings it causes people to spend
more money which causes prices to rise
which hurts which hurts people who are
the lowest
income among us and eventually means
that people who are buying american debt
realize they're gonna be paid off in
inflated dollars
and because you're gonna have to put
dollars into the system in order to keep
maintaining that system
jamie dimon chief executive of jp morgan
is among those tracking the inflation
threat he says there's a very good
chance you're gonna have a gangbuster
economy for the rest of the year and
easily into 2022.
the question is does that overheat
everything in addition to the 1.9
trillion dollars about to pour forth
diamond said
one trillion dollars in savings that
piled up during the pandemic remains
unspent
there's not a shortage of money there's
the shortage of places you spend
the money because people have not been
out and about but now they're out and
about and we're pouring money to the
economy
anyway diamond said i wouldn't buy
10-year treasuries
that's correct why would you buy bonds
it's gonna be very hard for america to
take out more debt
given the fact that we've already blown
out the debt and everybody knows we're
going to inflate
the volatile bond trading prompted
several unnerving days on wall street
last week high flying tech stocks were
particularly upended though broad share
indices remained
near record highs simon said i would
suspect there's a pretty good chance
you're going to see rates going up
and people are starting to worry about
that yep you're starting to see an
uptick in mortgage rates
home prices have been surging but a
sustained rise in borrowing costs would
almost certainly undermine
that trend as well eventually you'll get
the inflation and then you'll get
stagnation that is what's going to
happen over the course of the next i
would say
five to ten years because of what we are
doing right now and we don't care
right because right now it's it's good
times but there will be
a cost to this plus again endemic
poverty is not going to be cured just by
signing people checks we've tried this
before
it is always a failure but the democrats
are already shifting
how they talk about this because they
understand democrats do that this is
really not about
covert relief at all this is about
something else completely restructuring
the american economy
we'll get to that in just one moment
first when you're running a business hr
issues can absolutely kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations and hr
managers salaries aren't cheap they're
an average of 70 000 bucks a year
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was created
specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy and maintain your compliance
all for just 99 bucks a month
with bambi you can change hr from your
biggest liability to your biggest
strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business and
help you manage
your employees day-to-day all for just
99 bucks a month
month-to-month no hidden fees you can
cancel any time you didn't start your
business because you wanted to spend
time on hr compliance
let bambi help get your free hr audits
today go to bambi.com
shapiro right now to schedule your free
hr audit that is bambi.com
shapiro it's spelled b-a-m-b-e-e dot com
shapiro bambi dot com slash bureau go
check them out right now shore up all of
your hr problems and make sure that you
don't have hr liabilities in the future
by heading on over to bambi.com
shapiro all right well i truly believe
the world would be a better place if
people spend as much time reading books
as they do scrolling through social
media
if you agree with me and you've been
looking for a new title to check out
look no further
the new york times bestselling author
renowned podcast is none other than our
very own andrew clavin just released the
third
and final installment in his another
kingdom series the emperor's sword finds
austin lively on the run between two
realities as his enemies close in on all
sides
despite wild success in life he begins
to realize that a recurring vision is
actually a nightmare in disguise he's
caught in the coils of a terrible magic
the only way he can save his soul
is to give up his success re-enter the
11 lands and find
the emperor anastasius so he can restore
queen elinda to her throne
if you haven't read the first two books
you should totally read them they're
great the first two books did not
disappoint
i'll be sitting down to find out how
this last one concludes austin's
adventures the emperor's sword
it's now available for purchase online
head on over to amazon.com search
the emperor's sword also last november
we announced the one and only candace
owns would be joining the delaware
family well
the long wait is over i'm thrilled to
announce the daily wire's newest show
candace premieres next friday
march 19th no one triggers the left
quite like candace that is for sure
whether she is going after harry styles
wearing a dress or getting into a
twitter war with cardi b
many have tried to cancel candace all
have failed and candice obviously has
been
one of the more prominent people on
social media throughout the past few
years
i would expect that is not going to
change with the new show in 2018 candice
kicked off the blexit foundation it aims
to change the narrative that surrounds
america's minority communities she's
also the author of the new york times
bestseller
blackout how black america can make its
second escape from the democrat
plantation
get to know candace the real candice
every single week as she shares her
humor insight and defies all of the
stereotypes
starting next friday march 19th candice
will be exclusive to daily wire members
if you aren't a member yet head on over
to dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off
that is dailywire.com subscribe use code
candace for 25 percent off you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so here's the thing right now this covid
quote-unquote relief bill which is not a
covered relief bill is extremely popular
with the american people some 75 percent
of americans say that they love it
because of course it's free money and
because the media have been just
pushing this thing like absolute crazy i
mean they've been saying it's the most
important bill
since the advent of time since god
invented humanity this is the most
important thing that has ever happened
so people are very into it but
as this thing rolls out and as people go
back to work
all they're going to remember are the
downsides because there will be costs to
this
because the economy was going to go
anyway nobody is going to really
attribute the uptick in the economy to
this
nobody they might like the temporary
money for a little while but it ain't
going to last
forever and that is why democrats are
already trying to shift the narrative
they're trying to shift the narrative
into this is poverty fighting
right that's what this is well here's
the thing americans on a gut level
understand
that fighting poverty by just
helicoptering cash to people
does not actually solve poverty we've
tried this over and over in american
life so democrats are in a bit of a bind
here that's why they need kova to
continue if kova doesn't continue they
can't continue to force forward
all this radical policy with president
house plan sitting here talking about
how it's going to cure covet
the empath in chief okay that's not
going to work anymore
so they've started to push forward the
idea that this is all about poverty
relief but
i don't think that's going to be quite
as popular according to
the washington post at first the
democrats described their 1.9 trillion
stimulus as a response to a
once-in-a-century economic and health
emergency
but then language began to shift
something much different an anti-poverty
measure with few precedents
in u.s history yes you can see what
they're doing here
okay but here's the thing it ain't going
to con it ain't going to cure poverty we
all know this and it's going to have a
bad effect
we're just going to do all the same
policies economically as the 1960s
and we'll have the exact same result and
then we'll pretend that it had nothing
to do with the policy
so good luck to democrats on this i
think that
they are all the people who are very
optimistic about democratic prospects
because of this bill
remember barack obama put forth 800
billion dollars
in stimulus in his first year in office
and two years later
his party had lost congress so i really
have serious doubts about whether this
is actually
going to be the bonanza the democrats
that seem to think it's going to be for
them politically now one difference
is that the recession that obama
inherited was a very real economic
recession this one is pretty false this
one is an artificial recession
it was created by covet covered we'll
end it we'll go back to we'll go back to
regular
and so i don't think that the economy is
going to be in the state of collapse by
2022 or that we're going to be in a
state of slow recovery
in fact there's a lot of danger of the
economy quote unquote overheating but
by 2024 you're going to start to see the
effect of all of this meanwhile
the in actual crisis so it's not a
covenant's not a crisis anymore but
we're pretending it's a crisis
an actual crisis is happening at our
southern border
according to the washington post they're
now calling it a crisis
the united states currently holds 30
percent more minors
in adult detention centers at under joe
biden than it did at any time
during the trump administration remember
it was all kids in cages for
donald trump well now 30 more kids are
being held in cages by joe biden
and apparently it's not a crisis
according to joe biden and team
according to the washington post however
the magnitude of the crisis facing biden
at the u.s mexico border came in into
clearer focus on wednesday as the new
administration was holding record
numbers of unaccompanied migrant teens
and children in detention cells for far
longer than legally allowed and federal
health officials fell further behind
in their race to find space for them in
shelters but here's the thing it's not a
crisis that faces biden it is a crisis
created by biden
the wave of migrants they are attempting
to get in because they believe that
biden is about to amnesty them
and everybody acknowledges it's a crisis
but you have to know that this is a
crisis that was created solely and
specifically by the biden white house
which of course is the reason why the
biden white house refuses to acknowledge
that it is a crisis in the first place
the washington post has now called it a
crisis
cnn now calls it a crisis according to
fox news
there have now been a hundred thousand
border encounters in february that is a
100 increase over the prior year that is
solely and completely due to joe biden
but over and over and over again the
body administration insists it's not a
crisis so here's white house border
coordinator roberta jackson
she refuses to say that it's a crisis
it's not a crisis of course
would you describe what's happening on
the border as a crisis
given how these numbers are spiking so
much week by week
you know i think that i i really i'm not
trying to be cute here but i think the
fact of the matter is
we have to do what we do regardless of
what anybody calls the situation and the
fact is
we are all focused on improving the
situation
on changing to a more humane
and efficient system um well um it's a
crisis
and by the way when you say humane and
efficient system what you mean is you're
just going to release people into the
interior
that's all you mean the reason that
unaccompanied minors are showing up at
the border
right you have to wonder why
unaccompanied minors is because they're
not going to be deported
is because they're going to be allowed
into the country and everybody knows
this
and this is why i mean she basically
acknowledges this right roberta jackson
says
you know these surges the surges that
are happening it's because they're
responding to hope that is correct
their hope is that they will be given
amnesty because joe biden will give them
amnesty
we've seen surges before surges tend to
respond
to hope and there was a significant hope
for a more humane policy after
four years of you know pent up demand
i think what we are doing is making sure
that we respond to that hope
for people who need protection we
respond to that hope in a way
that their cases can be adjudicated more
quickly okay except that you guys
refused to fund last year during trump's
administration
any of the resources necessary to
actually adjudicate cases quickly it's
not about adjudicating cases quickly
it's about releasing people into the
interior everybody knows that that's why
you have this giant rush
to the border but again the message from
the abide in white house is that kovit
continues to be a crisis although now
it's on the way in because he's fixed
everything
he has to declare victory on covet after
spending five minutes in office and
inheriting all of trump's programs and
then doing virtually nothing
to make things better he gets to claim
victory on that over time but it's still
kind of a crisis if you need to push
forward another couple of trillion bucks
in spending
but it's not a crisis at the border when
your explicit policy causes a crisis at
the border here's secretary of state
tony blinken
again not admitting crisis at the border
just refusing
surely the absence of your contradicting
the idea that there's a crisis in the
border
does not should not be construed as you
are
consenting to the fact that there's a
crisis at the border
is there a crisis at the border
we have uh at the border a lot of a lot
of work to do to make sure that it
uh is uh safe orderly and humane we're
engaged
uh doing that work
so again not a crisis not a crisis it's
a crisis and it's been caused
by them it's the biden administration
once again pursuing radical policy as
radical policy as any
administration in my lifetime and we are
supposed to believe that it's all
moderate and popular because president
house plants is over there being
non-threatening because basically he's
not sentient so that's exciting stuff
meanwhile
the the new york times has discovered a
person they will actually defend which
is exciting
yeah actually there are a couple people
they've defended they've defended nicole
hannah jones even though she is a
fiction writer masquerading
as a reporter and even though she's a
bully inside the newsroom they won't
defend james bennett the former op-ed
editor who essentially got fired for
running a tom cotton op-ed they won't
defend barry weiss
who was called a nazi within the
newsroom they obviously won't spend
donald mcneil they'll get him fired for
the great sin of having suggested that
there are differences in the use of the
n-word based on context
all of that is is stuff that is not
worthy of defense but taylor lorenz who
is
one of the worst reporters in the new
york times all taylor lorenz does is
troll around on the internet find
people's battle tweets and then try to
destroy their careers
she's a bully and she is a falsifier of
information she she went
into clubhouse and she claimed that
people had been making comments they
absolutely did not make
well they're a bunch of people who
finally got up tight with taylor lorenz
because taylor lorenz
tweeted out and i'm saying her full name
here because that's her name i know this
is considered somehow bullying
and harassment if you say somebody's
full name i say people's full names on
this program an awful lot
because that's how i distinguish them
from other human beings members of the
media just so you know
okay so taylor lorenz who nobody had
heard of until she started tweeting out
about how she was the biggest victim in
the world a lot of people started making
fun of her
and then tucker carlson mentioned that
she was not actually a victim
in american society writ large and the
new york times put out a statement
rushing to her defense quote in a now
familiar move tucker carlson opened his
show last night by attacking a
journalist
it was a calculated and cruel tactic
which she regularly deploys to unleash a
wave of harassment and vitriol at his
intended target
taylor lorenz is a talented new york
times journalist fact check false
doing timely and essential reporting
fact check false
journalists should be able to do their
jobs without facing harassment
so does this count as harassment of
tucker carlson since they're criticizing
him and attacking a journalist
i love the the new rules are that the
reporters at the new york times can
attack you the common american citizen
they can un
they can dig up your past find all your
battle tweets find all your friends from
high school
that's fine but it is also worthy of
note that if you criticize them
then you must be ousted okay the sort of
woke solidarity movement inside the
media is truly astonishing
it really is they don't care about
freedom of speech and they don't care
about individual rights
they don't care about openness what they
care about is defending their own
and anybody who by the way crosses over
and attempts to have conversations with
anybody on the other side becomes a bad
person
so for example marlo stern who's the
idiot entertainment writer
for the daily beast the entertainment
editor i believe senior entertainment
editor for the daily beast
tweeted out quote i hope he said
remember this bleep remember this bleep
and it's about andrew yang so andrew
yang is now running for mayor of new
york henry yang happens to be a nice guy
andre yang did a sunday special with me
he was the only democratic candidate to
do so we invited every single democratic
candidate to come on the show
he's the only one who responded very
friendly dude we had an hour-long
conversation about universal basic
income it was quite cordial
apparently marlo stern thinks you should
not be allowed to vote for andrew yang
in new york or you should not vote for
andrew yang because he appeared on a
show with the person who disagreed
but don't worry our media are all for
free speech they're all for first
amendment they're all for
your ability to speak freely except that
you're not allowed to criticize them or
appear on any show
of which they disapprove i will note
here
that it is quite astonishing how few
members of the american media have come
to the defense of piers morgan
in the uk so piers morgan of course lost
his job at good morning britain for the
great sin
of having said he didn't believe meghan
markle okay i also have said i do not
believe
some things that meghan markle has said
by the way the royal family is now
denying
that they did a lot of the stuff that
she's claiming they did right
prince william came out yesterday he
said we are very much not a racist
family
so he denies all of these charges about
how it's racism that drove megan markle
from buckingham palace or anything like
that i said i didn't believe meghan
markle
because she seems frankly to me like a
person who's attempting to make the most
of her situation for fame and money
piers morgan said the same thing but
meghan markle then contacted his
employer with a complaint
he was investigated by the british
government regulator and he lost his job
so appears morgan came out and he said
i still believe in freedom of speech i
believe in freedom of speech
i believe in the right to uh be allowed
to have an opinion
uh if people want to believe meghan
markle that's entirely their right
i don't believe almost anything that
comes out of her mouth and i think the
damage she's done
to the british monarchy and to the queen
at a time when prince philip
is lying in hospital is enormous
and frankly contemptible so uh if i have
to fall on my sword for expressing an
honestly held opinion
about meghan markle and that dire tribe
of bilge that she came out with in that
interview
so be it okay what's hilarious about
this of course the american media
are all over piers morgan right most of
the american media are angry at piers
morgan for having said that even though
he lost his job for saying a thing
by the way it goes further than that in
britain this is a story from yesterday
the huffington post in great britain the
head of an industry body for the uk
press has now resigned
following a backlash for claiming that
the uk media is not racist
ian murray is executive director of the
society of editors he said he would step
down from his role so the organization
can quote
rebuild its reputation after publishing
a widely ridiculed claim that the uk
media is quote unquote not bigoted
in a statement published on monday that
sparked a backlash against the
organization
he wrote the uk media has never shied
away from holding a spotlight up to
those in positions of power
celebrity or influence if sometimes the
questions asked are awkward and
embarrassing then so be it but the press
is most certainly not racist
his assertion when she went on to defend
in a heated interview with victoria
derbyshire on tuesday was fiercely
criticized by members of the soes on
board so you've got the society of
editors which is supposed to be the
editors of the british press
who are now suggesting that you ought to
be fired as the head of the editors of
the british press
for saying that they are not racist
apparently they want the head of their
own organization to declare them racist
and if he doesn't they will get him
fired that is how perverse woke ideology
has become
not only do you feel a sense of joy in
denouncing your own racism
if somebody else says you're not a
racist that person should be finished
their career should be ended
the soe in britain represents almost 400
members in senior positions across the
uk media
several of whom have now publicly
declared their opposition to murray's
statement
award-winning journalist and loose women
panelist charlene white announced she
had pulled out of hosting
the society of editors national press
awards white cited the much criticized
statement released on monday in the wake
of harry and megan's interview with
oprah winfrey
perhaps it's best for you to look
elsewhere for a host for your awards
this year she said perhaps someone who's
views a line with yours that the uk
press is the one institution in the
entire country has a perfect record on
race of course that's not what he's
saying
there are racist people he's saying that
overall the british press were not
racist
and members of the british press were
like how dare you sir
because everything is racist guys every
single thing and if you refuse to
denounce
not only your own racism but everybody
else's racism this makes you a racist
this is the woke ideology in action
okay 167 journalists of color across the
british media industry signed an open
letter to say they deplored and rejected
the society of editor's statement quote
while megan's comments
shone a light on her own personal
experiences of discriminatory treatment
they reflect the depressingly familiar
reality
of how people from black asian and
minority ethnic backgrounds are
portrayed by the uk press
on a daily basis the society of editors
claim that the
sussex view that would be harry and
megan were made without supporting
evidence shows a willful ignorance of
not just the discriminatory treatment of
megan
some of which was highlighted during the
interview but that of other people from
an ethnic minority background
murray said he would step down from his
role he said well i do not agree that
the society society's statement was in
any way intended to defend racism
i accept it could have been much clearer
in its condemnation of bigotry and has
clearly caused upset
so i'm stepping aside so the
organization can rebuild its reputation
this is how bad our press has become on
both sides of the water by the way
our press is so bad that not only will
they not defend somebody who loses their
job for expressing an honestly held
opinion that is well within the
mainstream
51 percent of the british public
believes that harry and megan should
lose their titles
but they will actually the press will
oust its own members
for having the temerity to say this sort
of stuff
our institutions have been taken over by
the woke and militarized by the world
and and they will not allow any descent
by the way if you descend from this
opinion this makes you racist they
believe in the ibram candy nonsense that
if you declare that you're not racist
after somebody calls you a racist this
just makes you more racist
over on this side of the water obviously
you have reporters like cnn's don lemon
who is such a journalist i mean this guy
he journalism's everywhere every single
night he journalisms and
my goodness the levels of journalism so
last night don lemon over at cnn was
very
upset with tim scott senator tim scott
had said that woke supremacy right now
not
historically because woke supremacy
didn't exist historically he's saying
woke supremacy meaning
people who want to separate americans
based on race and then use institutions
of power to quash their opponents
those people are worse than white
supremacists or as bad as white
supremacists
which by the way is true okay white
supremacists and woke supremacists have
a lot in common they see the world in
terms of race they seek to use their
institutional power in order to quash
people of other races they suggest that
if you disagree with them it's because
you're intellectually or morally
inferior
but don lemon is in fact a woke
supremacist right he actually believes
in critical racial theory
and and wokeness he believes in it so
much that he doesn't even care about
basic journalistic standards
and you'll remember that don lemon over
the past few days has announced you
don't even need to hear the other side
of the story
from the royal family because meghan
markle obviously is saying so many
things that are so obviously true to don
lemon
that hearing the other side of the story
would be unwoke and so we shouldn't hear
from the other side which is a hell of a
thing for a purported journalist to say
well now
don lemon goes after tim scott in
possibly the dumbest possible way
i didn't see any
ropes woke supremacist storming the the
blanken capital
where the woke supremacist attacking
police
where the woke supremacist hunting
police officers
in the halls of the capitol and beating
them with blue lives matter signs
with white supremacist insignia on their
shirts
and carrying white supremacist
paraphernalia
guess who i saw guess who police
officers were beaten by
guess who wanted to hang the vice
president white supremacist tim scott
what are you doing
so much journalism happening right there
because woke supremacists have never
done any damage to the united states you
know i mean
i mean other than the 2 billion 2
billion dollars in property damage that
they did last year in rioting all around
the country
other than that it's been totally fine
the whole supremacists are not a threat
in any way they're not a threat to you
they're not a threat to cops they're not
a threat to cities they don't burn
things down
they don't take over institutions by the
way they do all of those things and not
only do they do all of those things they
have
tremendous institutional power white
supremacists don't have a lot of
institutional power
i mean i can't name an institution in
the united states that actually
advocates white supremacy in the
classical definition not in the ibrahmax
candy white supremacy definition which
just means anybody who disagrees with
ibramax candy is a white supremacist
i mean like actual white supremacists
who believe that white people are
superior because they're morons
right there is no institutional power
for those people in the united states
there is tremendous institutional power
for the woke supremacists across the
united states
okay and that makes a difference both
ideologies are evil only one has
tremendous influential sway
only one has now infiltrated pretty much
every major institution in american
society
john morrowski over real clear
investigations has a fascinating piece
today
about how california the entire state is
embracing mandatory racial injustice
study for all of its 1.7 million high
schoolers
quote california has struggled for five
years to create a politically palatable
ethnic studies curriculum that would
teach high schoolers how systemic racism
predatory capitalism heteropatriarchy
and quote other structures of oppression
are foundational to american society and
this is woke supremacy
now after more than 82 000 public
comments and four major rewrites the
state board of education
is expected to approve the latest
version next week clearing the way for
lawmakers to make a semester-long course
in the material
a graduation requirement for all of
california's 1.7 million
high school students the latest
curriculum however scale back
still shares similarities with an
earlier rejected draft a top state
official said failed to comply with
state law
the la times editorial board
characterized it as a jumble of quote
politically correct pronouncements that
feel like an exercising group think
designed to proselytize and inculcate
more than to inform and open minds
okay by the way if the l.a times
editorial board is ripping you as too
woke
you're way off the deep end the la times
editorial board is one of the most
left-leaning editorial boards in america
according to real clear investigations
when all is said and done the material
emphasizes
white subjugation of non-whites it's not
a conventional textbook subject but an
ideology with an activist political
agenda
revisions may never satisfy parents and
teachers who believe public schools
shouldn't be in the business of teaching
kids how to develop a quote unquote
social consciousness
or using class time to pinpoint a
student's intersectional identity to
determine where they fit on a hierarchy
of power
at the same time ethnic studies
activists are furious that their efforts
at promoting social justice and
centering
voices of colors are being deluded by as
they put it power structures such as
whiteness zionism and assimilationism
passage of the landmark curriculum at
the board's scheduled meeting on march
18th should mark a hard-fought victory
for the half-century old ethnic studies
movement and help advocates promote
their movement across the country it
won't end the conflict in california
where the issue will then be forced to
the local level to be decided by local
school boards or in
individual classrooms the reason is
because state guidelines grant teachers
wide flexibility in how they teach
the subject but advocates aren't happy
with that they want a state
cram down on this stuff they insist on
hewing to a heroic narrative
about how people of color have suffered
and fought against european capitalism
colonialism and imperialism
practitioners have formed their own
organization the liberated ethnic
studies model curriculum institute
for the past year activists have been
meeting in online sessions to hash out
strategy
expound upon their liberatory and
transformational ideology
and encourage educators to teach the
full strength curriculum that the state
has already flunked the liberated ethnic
studies group includes many of the
original authors of the 2019 ethnic
studies model curriculum the state has
gutted as well as 50 scholars teachers
practitioners and students
according to ellison tintian cubales an
asian american studies professor at san
francisco state university
the advocates say many state officials
fail to grasp ethnic studies is not a
traditional school subject
but a movement and a philosophy best
described as narrative medicine
radical healing and even a way of life
and these folks will gain institutional
power and they will use that
institutional power in order to cram
this crap
down on you and when don lemon suggests
that woke supremacy means nothing he is
speaking from his position
as a cnn anchor at the most widely
respected news network in america
speaking as a person who believes in
critical racial theory
and wokeness okay and everybody who
disagrees will be ousted
and people who suggest that the press
are not racist will be ousted
okay the woke are coming for everyone
they're coming for all the standards
on the governmental level we are now
enmeshed in a complete rethinking of the
nature
of the relationship between government
and the individual government is going
to take care of all of your needs all
you have to do is sacrifice your
self-respect
sacrifice your rights sacrifice your
freedoms and the government will take
care of everything for you
the government will rectify all past
injustices all you have to do is pledge
your fealty to an overarching state
and a media infrastructure that acts as
this propaganda wing that's all you have
to do and everything will be all better
all of this done under the auspices of
president house plans and his compliant
media
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airs
at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 on the matt welsh show we talk
about the things that matter real issues
that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show